today amazon ceo that's jeff bezos
officially steps aside as head of the
company that he founded exactly
27 years ago here's a look back at his
60 minutes interview with the late
bob simon this was in 1999.
the way i made the decision to leave
wall street and do this was
you know sound geeky to you but um it
was a regret minimization framework
so this is how i actually made it so if
i understand that if i can translate
that into
english i can deal with does that mean
um
i want to live my life so that in a few
decades from now i'm not going to regret
it that's exactly right
i want to have lived my life in such a
way that when i'm 80 years old i've
minimized the number of regrets that i
have
and i think actually a lot of people do
that i think that even if they don't you
know call it something as dorky as
regret minimization framework
they they behave that way anyway they
think that way
and but for you it was not carpe diem it
was not wine women in song
no no no no i i don't go in for carpe
diem i go in for regret minimization
framework
[Music]
[Laughter]
jeff bezos looks a little different huh
but his laugh is still the same he will
remain his executive chairman
he's handing over the ceo reigns to andy
jassy the founder of amazon's successful
cloud computing division
amazon is now one of the world's largest
and most valuable companies
valued at 1.7 trillion dollars with the
t
bezos is the world's wealthiest person
worth more than 200 billion dollars with
a b
that's according to forbes magazine
thank you for pointing those teasers out
but amid all that success the company
has often been accused of poor working
conditions at warehouses around the
country
and federal regulators are scrutinizing
the company for alleged anti-competitive
business practices
amazon says it invested more than one
billion dollars in new worker safety
programs in 2020
and said in part quote while any
incident is one too many we are
continuously
learning and seeing improvements we're
joined now by brad stone author of
amazon unbound jeff bezos
and the invention of a global empire
it's published by simon schuster a
division of icom cbs
he's also the senior executive editor
for global technology at bloomberg news
brad good morning to you
hi jamie good morning you know i want to
start i want to ask you about jeff bezos
in his run
as ceo but i want to start with
something you recently said you said the
hard work now
that jeff bezos is stepping down is
really going to fall on his colleagues
saying that
it's about finding amazon's heart can
you explain that
sure amazon employs 1.3 million people
and you know folks who pay attention to
the news
recognize that the depiction of amazon's
relationship with
its employees hasn't always been that
flattering particularly the workers in
the warehouses
now recently amazon did something
startling it added two
principles to its kind of sacrosanct
leadership values you can see them on
the website
and one was strive to be earth's best
employer and another was success and
scale bring broad responsibility
the company is basically saying it needs
to treat employees with more empathy
and consider social responsibility and
what it does and it is kind of
remarkable because for 27 years bezos
ran the company with one thing in mind
customers and growth and i think this is
an indication that maybe that
transactional relationship with
employees is going to have to change
it'll be interesting to watch that
definitely change the quantity and
quality of
labor in this country for sure can you
explain why jeff bezos's run as ceo was
so historic
right i mean this is really a moment to
recognize the accomplishment 27 years
ago he starts
amazon in the garage of a seattle area
home you know ironically he has a pair
of kind of
book-loving anti-capitalists to help him
so imagine their surprise
when amazon starts expanding in every
direction and the company has changed
how we shop
how we read how we talk to computers uh
with alexa and it's
it's its competitors and imitators and
how companies and universities and
governments access computing resources
which is a little arcane but this is
amazon's cloud division amazon web
services
so bezos is one of those unique ceos
who's been transformational
not just in one category but in a number
of industries
and amazon wasn't in the lexicon 25
years ago and today it's probably
the most famous company or at least one
of them in the world
right well yeah the incoming ceo andy
jassy
he joined amazon in 1997. you call him a
bezos disciple
how is he being groomed for this
position especially as all the eyes of
the world are really going to be on him
he was being groomed 20 years ago he was
the first so-called shadow or technical
advisor whose job was basically to be
bezos's chief of staff to follow him
around taking notes and meetings
and and then he went and ran amazon web
services and today that's a 50
billion a year uh annual revenue
business which is startling when when
you kind of consider it
he's on the s team so he sat in on all
the meetings
i i think you know he he'll he'll
continue uh bezos's philosophy
is his leadership but he'll probably be
a bit of a more empathetic
leader i'll give you one quick example
at his big amazon web services
conference last year which of course was
virtual
he started to talk he started out by
talking in his keynote about black lives
matter
and look as as socially aware as jeff
bezos might be
that's really never something that he
did as ceo of amazon
well we'll see if it becomes humble and
more friendly at amazon bradstone thank
you so much